cigarette sales increased in 2020 for
the first time in two decades more
americans bought cigarettes in 2020
according to a report by the federal
trade commission the increase happened
during the pandemic stressors such as a
pandemic lockdowns remote learning and
stay-at-home lifestyles may have
contributed to the increase in tobacco
purchase according to the report
manufacturers sold close to a billion
more cigarettes in 2020 compared to 2019
cigarette use isn't the only thing that
increased the use of e-cigarettes and
vape pens increase in 2022 between
february 2020 and march 2021 e-cigarette
sales increased from almost 15 million
to 22 million units ricky what do you
got to say about this you know i have a
buddy of mine that's a smoker right he's
been a smoker for 10 years
and uh he went from smoking one pack a
day to smoking two packs a day because
of the stress he was under during in
2020 because he got laid off you know
and all that so uh that's one and then
uh you know
we're all human uh naturally i think in
2020 22 or i'm sorry 2020 um i had seen
the e-cigarettes i never really paid
attention to them and uh and somebody
had them they're like oh it's like
cigarettes but it's not cigarettes right
i don't know i don't it has tobacco in
it and that's the first time i had ever
been like curious about it because i'm
not a smoker you know um but even a
person like me i'm pretty i feel like
i'm pretty strong minded uh you you
still like you try to find like a source
i mean i have you know i have adhd and i
don't know in aries so it's a bad
combination so you're always trying to
find a way to relieve stress so i i
totally can see apart from seeing it
firsthand with my friends and their
smokers doubling their smoking habits uh
even myself i'm like huh oh because he
had told me the person that told me that
he said
it helps you relieve stress and i said
wow that's that sounds like a good idea
but obviously you know it didn't go down
that route but just the idea that is
sport just the spark itself i'm sure
that out of those billion new cigarettes
not all of them are are
former smokers i'm sure a lot of them
are new smokers that picked up the habit
during the pandemic from the stress so
let me ask you a question all of you
guys here how many of you guys
no names how many guys know a lot of
people that smoke cigarettes yeah yeah
do you do you know yeah well especially
most people smoke cigarettes that i know
they smoke cigarettes after they're
drinking yeah you know you have a couple
drinks in you you go ahead outside you
have a dart you know what i mean and
that's that's how it goes dark that's
how you know you smoke some cigarettes
let me get a dark dark never heard that
so the uh
yeah the the
i've never heard that before the uh yeah
so you you don't like wake up in the
morning like you know in the movies and
you pop one i mean you're having a
couple drinks and what did everybody do
every day during the pandemic they got
they
everybody got drunk every day here in
the pandemic well maybe not down here
because we've discussed this at length
that you guys really weren't live all
your friends in new jersey were just
getting drunk at home yeah we were
literally on house arrest there was
nothing else to do the only things that
were open were fast food restaurants and
liquor stores that was literally all
that was you come down to florida you
lose 50 pounds literally there you go
like actually literally
just burgers he doesn't realize other
states exactly no i don't know
i stayed here
other states
you don't ask for the help's last name
i'm learning how many uber drivers last
names do you know go
uh zero dominguez velasquez
i have my own car i don't know
let me ask you this you drive uber every
single day not these days
last night do you know zero they don't
tell you their last name two ubers this
year how many ubers have you taken can
you name one
the only way to do it is to schedule
uber by the way with the cigarettes i
know i literally know more people who
have quit smoking than i know people who
actually smoke i'm with you i don't know
anybody that smokes i'm with you i don't
see them smoking in the bars california
probably has a lot fewer smokers here's
the interesting thing about this right
the pandemic caused this like gerard
said 100 percent it's the reason people
are smoking more
but after you get that little buzz it
actually increases your anxiety and your
tension wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait are you
saying smoking's bad for you right no
kidding right here's the other
fascinating thing about this
smokeless tobacco increased from 126
million pounds
to 129 million pounds they're measuring
this that's a lot of skull bandits
by the way i was in a gas station last
week and i saw two people back to back
come in and order chewing tobacco and
buy it
that's another thing you never see
anymore even baseball players i was in
florida right when i was leaving town so
i had a 15-year levi garrett habit for
sure did you i would imagine if you
played minor league baseball fields
chewing tobacco's uh copenhagen's like
god yeah because you can't smoke close
to the wellhead so gerard can probably
back this up because you and i are
probably the ones who hit the bars these
days these gen zers out there 18 21 25
whatever that age bracket the vape is
non-stop
like i'll look at a bar and they'll be
like boom boom boom just
vaping
like remember back in the day when there
would be a club and a dj would drop the
beat and then smoke would come out
everywhere yeah of course non-stop by
the way is it is it illegal to show
smoking in movies can you not do that
anymore i mean maybe
you never see it anymore it's so funny
you watch old school there's a stat here
that they didn't show because truth has
done a very good job of getting people
to stop smoking but there's someone out
there that has been probably the biggest
catalyst into smoking and that's max
apollo this guy makes people smoke
cigars left and right
cigars with the money smart guy in
six months then in 10 years shout out to
mata paul he make me make a call don't
don't show it yet don't show it don't go
down to the bottom okay question for you
price up a pack of cigarettes today okay
i'm going to go with him
i'm going to ask you i'm going to ask
you by state i'm going to ask you by
steve you guys
stop interrupting each other a little
bit that'd be good all right here we go
give me the price of cigarettes
in new york city one pack 12 bucks no
uh american spirits would probably be
like uh 19 between 19 and 21 bucks okay
so it's by the way
the fact that you know the number
concerns me a lot about just 12.85 okay
price of cigarettes a pack in illinois
1150 massachusetts 9.95 you can show it
now kai uh alaska's 979 vermont 962
hawaii 955 connecticut 952 washington 9
30 rhode island 895 wisconsin 8
82 for a pack of cigarettes if you're
smoking two packs of cigarettes a day in
california you spend 16 a day
you're spending eight bucks a day on
cigarettes here here's one rule i have i
this is gonna offend some people i don't
do business with people who smoke
cigarettes
i just don't simple as that you come to
my house how long does it take to smell
cigarettes how long does it take to
smell it's on their clothes if i sense
it i am buying i have a very simple rule
if i sense it i'm not buying cigarettes
the smell to me is something shaking
hands when you shake hands with somebody
that's that hand that that then you
where you were going to do business with
somebody and you said
sorry buddy if i could tell you 50 times
that's a small number 50 times that's a
small number but what do you mean what
type of business like a new anything
you're selling me anything you're doing
with me i'll have the conversation i'll
say can you tell me why you smoke
cigarettes
everything has a reason smoking
cigarettes doesn't have a reason why do
you drink alcohol okay you get a little
bit tipsy maybe it gives you a little
bit of a buzz fine that liquid curry
smoking weed okay fine smoking
cigarettes there is no argument on why
anybody should smoke cigarettes but here
you go 2020
people are supported stressed even the
french so you're not doing any business
with anybody the numbers really do
surprise me because
i'm i'm okay
let me just say this story it's already
too late anyways so i'm dating a a a
former miss i'm not going to say the
state so we're dating this was a few
years ago
and we're going out one day we're going
out we kiss
that was the last time we kissed
because you smoked cigarettes
i cannot do that if i if i have any
smell with cigarettes i can't do it to
me i can't do now you may call it a
weakness call a judgment say i judge
people whatever you want to call it i
cannot do cigarettes by the way another
pet peeve coffee stains you guys know
what coffee high work yeah you have no
idea for me to even think about that
thing sitting right there is two inches
away from dropping everything
okay everything to me with coffee
cigarettes some some people may call it
crazy a little bit you know i ran sales
offices for 15 years without letting
coffee in there mario and the guys mario
can tell you the story at a sales office
in in by the way if you were in the
granada hills office you're listening to
the podcast you can post it in the
comment section to verify this or if you
were in northridge you can verify this
guys would put their coffees outside the
uh office like literally the door is
here the coffees will be lined up 10 of
them here they could be outside but they
could have been inside anyways i have
something about cigarettes and coffee it
is what it is maybe i'll start drinking
coffee
though i mean because that that takes
you out of your zone because if you got
three people doing it the same thing
with me with people chewing gum i can't
deal with it i freak out every one of
you drinks coffee my wife loves coffee
my dad loves coffee my sister loves
coffee my own kids say mom can i have a
sip of that coffee right me i'm good did
someone spill hot coffee on you no there
was a stain there was a stain there was
a stain at the granada hills office that
i would have to look at every single day
when i came in i can't deal with snakes
by the way you know who drinks more
coffee than anyone i've ever seen in my
life who our friend mario this guy used
to go 10 cups a day it'd it'll be
midnight and he's ready for bed he's
like can i get a cup of coffee to go
it's insanity it's cold
why don't we do this espresso why don't
we do this what is the best coffee
machine
out there tell me what the best coffee
machine
is give me a coffee machine to buy how
much is a coffee machine what's 300. can
you pull up pull up a coffee machine
you're going to go through
what is the best coffee machine this is
what happens when you put this out there
be careful with your choice because
that's going to buy this it's nespresso
tell me
what's the best coffee machine you don't
like nespresso tell me one of the best
coffee machines give me a i'll give you
some a reason why because the computers
are inexpensive and it's good coffee not
keurig no french press man okay is that
the lonely all-in-one is that a good
coffee machine is that the one which one
that makes you know like legit barista
type coffee but you don't want to do
that go with an espresso you push one
button
okay xander knows his stuff about this
what's the deal with onions though
oh
don't get this man started on onion guys
great question everybody has a certain
gift one of my gifts is i'm gifted with
a big nose okay yeah which means i can
smell stuff from a mile away middle
easterns
i know what they're doing across the
street right now i can smell it it's one
of those things onions i come in david's
having onions i'm like what are you
doing okay one time robert our hr guy's
having onions he's trying to hide the
onions i'm like get that onion i feel
bad so bad for her carlos one time i
think this is like a second week he
usually warmed up his little lunch
whatever pat comes storming out of his
office onions who's got it
like coffee beans are cigarettes and
onions i could never live
first office php
dallas texas
we're in the conference room
we really screw up and we've lit pad up
okay you you and you my office we're
gonna process this we're walking down
the hall and there was this little tiny
break room that was there remember that
the two little the one table and
something and and paul s garciga
is
microwaving and reheating
fish from hell and as we walk past the
break room we all thank god for paul
because
he got distracted goes paul how could
you bring that in you of all the things
you can bring in the reheat for your
lunch you bring this in this is horrible
this stinks
and
suddenly we got to his office
there's a lesson here
you're in trouble with pat like
yesterday i was a little late i was a
little bit in trouble
just have someone show up with some
onions just call it from the bullpen get
an onion guy
kenny max are you coming
you're relaxing i got a meeting with pat
it's not going to be a good meeting can
you do me a favor and order a chalupa
with an extraordinary onion guy so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]